this week on quadriga Syrian future a
role for Assad the civil war in Syria
has gone into its fifth year and no end
is in sight more than 220,000 people are
estimated to have been killed in the
conflict and almost half the population
has been displaced now the US has
signaled it may be ready for compromise
US Secretary of State John Kerry has
said the US would have to negotiate with
the Assad regime and was exploring ways
of relaunching talks to get the Assad
regime to negotiate we're going to have
to make it clear to him that there is a
determination by everybody to seek that
political come and change his
calculation about negotiating until now
the US and other Western countries had
insisted Assad could play no role in the
future of Syria the Syrian opposition as
well as turkey Britain and France have
rejected to us about face your host this
week Melinda crane hello and welcome it
took the rapid rise of the radical
jihadist group Isis to finally focus
attention on the ongoing war in Syria
and that despite the fact that far more
people have died at the hands of Assads
forces than at those of Isis will the
new focus result in a truly realistic
and committed effort to end the fighting
even if it means sitting down with Assad
that's what we want to talk about today
with three people who are following the
conflict in Syria very closely it's my
pleasure to welcome Kristen helberg she
was based in Syria from 2001 to 2009 as
a freelance correspondent for various
German broadcasters and print media she
continues to report regularly from the
Middle East and we're welcoming fawaz
Telo he is part of Syria's secular
opposition movement and one of the
founding members of the National Council
of the Damascus declaration he's been
living in exile in germany since 2012
and finally a pleasure to welcome Andrew
Dennison back to the show he is the
director of the research the research
consortium transatlantic networks he
analyzes international and domestic
security policy with a particular focus
on the Obama
stration thought was tell oh I know that
you suffered at the hands of the Assad
regime they imprisoned you I believe
from 2001 to 2006 but after four years
of war in the face of disintegration
across the region would you say it's
time to simply do what it takes to end
this fighting even if it means
negotiating with Assad let me start that
his evolution is not the wall it's not
civil war it started evolution and they
will stay at evolution in spite there's
some effects here or there including the
ISIS here on there and yes all this the
most of the Syrian people say think that
it was the good a good decision to this
to destroy this wall of fear ins inside
them and start this revolution and I
think a revolution without a goal to be
finished there's no soap so bad while
there is not a half revolution tell now
you are talking about 200,000 people
actually the real the real figures could
be reached double that of that figure we
have walked virtual quarter million
detainees indeed nom 12-minute refugee
and the regime is already having a very
very bad military approach for for
philosophy we're going to take a look at
the situation a little bit later in the
program in detail but yes or no
negotiate with Assad or not no it's it's
it's like throwing oil over the the fire
this is what's happening now I it's
useless Andrew Denison last year was the
very bloodiest year in the conflict so
far we just heard some of the statistics
76,000 Syrians died in 2014 Isis now
controls half the country is it time to
do whatever it takes isn't the risk of
allowing this conflict to continue even
great
then the risk is sitting down with Assad
well yes and sitting down with Assad let
me come to that in a second first of all
your point conflict is getting worse
civil wars do that they don't just
automatically go out they tend to get
worse and worse and worse until
something dramatic happens all the
parties are exhausted are dead are
incapable of fighting or in our global
age the outside world comes in and tries
to put the pressure on the different
parties now as horrible as Assad is I do
not believe that negotiations can arrive
at an agreement that do not reflect the
realities of power on the ground and
Assads government controls large parts
of Syria not all of it but parts of it
and if you want a ceasefire much less
some sort of sustainable political order
to stop the bloodshed I think you have
to talk to all the powers on the ground
even I mean at some point is some people
in Isis we're gonna least have to try to
talk to him now i should say in the
Middle East often times you sit down to
negotiate with an enemy and one of you
pulls out a pistol and blows the other
guy away or blows them up so it's not as
if when you're negotiating with each
other you're necessarily going to be
friends it may be very dangerous but I
don't think we should rule out
negotiating with Assad kristin helberg I
know you've taken the opposite point of
view in the past you've said Assad
should not be viewed as the lesser of
two evils and he's no bulwark against
terrorism but you wrote that more than a
year ago before the bloodiest year of
the conflict so far is there really a
feasible alternative to negotiating with
Assad no there's a big difference he's
the origin of the problem but this
doesn't mean that we should not talk to
his regime obviously and this is nothing
new we have been seeing talks and
negotiations between opposition and with
representatives of this regime engineer
twice there's nothing new about what
John Kerry said there's nothing new
about what foreign ministers sayanaya
said this conflict will end at the
negotiating table the problem is and
this is the interesting point John Kerry
said how do we get a child answer to
this table ready to compromise because
Bashar Assad has no reason to compromise
on anything right now so what we need is
more pressure military pressure on the
Assad regime
to be able to sit there to find a
solution that means a real transition of
power and by the way all the opposition
fractions agree that the exit of acid is
not a prerequisite and he has not to
live before negotiating but in the end
of a true negotiating process a real
transition of power must be there in the
future cannot be with us are consumed
does that help at all to bridge the gap
between the positions here of West lof
we say that we need to distinguish
between the short term and the long term
is there perhaps a potential for a deal
where Assad would stay in power just for
a transitional period to end the
fighting that apparently is the path
that is currently being advocated by the
UN special envoy for Syria he says look
to end the fighting to end the
destruction in a lepa we need to talk to
Assad but only for the short-term
solution not for the long-term one I
think what's mr. de Mistura is proposing
is not a special envoy just for Arsenal
for ya actually he is not proposing any
political solution is just some handling
some problems or some destruction were
here on there and to deal with negotiate
with I said I think why the world
doesn't negotiate with Isis are also
like look in Syria yes we are ready to
speak with the people of the regime I
mean the other issue is controlling
Syrian now but but not with the shot
Assad and some big officers who is
rolling all the destruction on all these
crimes I think the first priority for
the international community not to have
a power not to speak with Bashar Assad
but to get Bashar Assad out of the scene
anyway and after that people from inside
the regime we can sit with them and
negotiate for the this will be a good
approach otherwise I think we are using
that wasting that time and i will want
to distinguish here between the priority
of the international unity
you mentioned that before 11 year the
ISIS world became so powerful and
controlling one or three of the serious
cetera chatter okay before that Isis was
not exist Isis as a result is a result
of political failure of the
international community of dealing with
with the Syrian problem you have to
leave the Syrian problem to get rid of
Isis not not only to send some jet
fighter firefighters to bear them and
believe me there is priority for the
internationally now is Isis the Syrian
on the region and the Iraqis indica it's
not the same priority the first relative
to get rid of the sick terrier regime to
have a democratic civil circular stage
which the international community can
play a very good rule when be a partner
with this process yes Isis is problem
and who can fight ISIL on the ground in
the Sunnis in the river and it means
that people who is mainly having this
revolution inside Syria all those people
who is suffering in Iraq needs to build
a real partnership with these groups to
get rid of Isis I want to come back to
that in just a moment to talk about the
opposition but perhaps it does seem
Kristen helberg that many people within
the international community are now
coming around to the way of thinking
that we actually do need to solve the
Syrian Revolution civil war in order to
stop the rampage of Isis across the
region your own foreign minister of fun
Faldo Steinmeier said this week the only
way to end the violence is negotiations
for a political solution even if that
makes talks with the Assad regime
necessary would you agree that's okay to
solve the whole political crisis in big
negotiations this will be with people
from the Assad regime I just said this i
think the major fear of people of
syrians the major fear is that now we
miss understand bashar al-assad as a
partner in the fight against terrorism
this is the main point that people think
and this has come up some people have
come up with this in western capitals
they say well you know
he is the lesser of two evils so let's
fight Isis with Bashar Assad so this is
a very wrong conception and this is
people who don't know and understand the
very dynamics in Syria because Bashar
Assad himself as far as tell you just
mentioned he is the reason for Isis
growing up he has always gone after the
moderates he's fighting the moderate
rebels the model is the activists on the
ground these are the people that Bashar
Assad had gone after he left the jihadis
out of his he freed them from his
prisons he let them grow inside the
country because he needs them to present
himself as the big protector of
minorities and you know as the one who
is fighting terrorism inside his country
so we don't we should not misunderstand
he cannot be a partner and nobody's I
think thinking about going to Damascus
and shake hands with Bashar al-assad
nobody thinks about this nobody says
this even steinmeier said yes in the end
we have to negotiate everybody agrees
but to to God get to a real negotiating
process we have to change some military
things on the ground and just let me
finish with one point Bashar Assad does
not control his areas by himself we have
a lot of protégée militias that have
grown out of the shabiha militias in the
beginning that have a very strong say
locally and they don't necessarily
listen to what the presidential palace
in Damascus says so he is not in control
he is listening to orders from Tehran
Iran is very important player in the
military play inside the country and
Hizballah Bernice's bola so Bashar Assad
cannot even be a partner because he's
weak me literally elder jenison Kristen
hallberg told us we must not
misunderstand what Assad can or cannot
do sometimes it looks like there is a
bit of confusion in Washington on this
point shortly after the Secretary of
State Kerry made the remarks that we saw
in our introductory report an envoi here
at a meeting in Berlin with Frank
valdosta on Mar the Foreign Minister
took it all back and said no we're not
thinking of negotiating with Assad
meanwhile Assad says airstrikes against
Isis are being coordinated indirectly
through Iraq in other words the US
apparently does see him at least
indirectly as a partner in the fight
against
this does Washington have a clear
strategy here well it's easy to
misunderstand Washington just like it's
easy to misunderstand Syria and what
will affect Assads calculations I think
at least the president wants to stay out
of this fight kick the can down the road
that's the oldest the rule in the
political book he's only got two more
years left he's been in Afghanistan and
Iraq he doesn't want to get in so he
does as little as possible the
beheadings created a political firestorm
so he had to start launching airstrikes
but even then he was saying we're not
going to be e rocks are me much less
take on Syria now why does carry at this
point say I might talk to Assad but he
didn't say this well or whatever his
little a firestorm that he created I
think it has to do with his negotiations
with Iran in that moving Iran also has
to do with how we position ourselves via
the Assad government and of course if we
got help from Iran in Syria it would be
great and if ron was as dependent on the
Russians they are now that would be
great too which comes back to your point
you said that talking to the Assad
government isn't going to change
anything and I agree with that just cuz
we say we're gonna talk to him doesn't
change the military reality on the
ground which is that Assad still has
power to rule large swathes of territory
help Oh Iran and with the help of Iran
and and all others in Russia to not
binding on florin right so we would like
it but um we've been at this for four
years and all along we've said there's
no military pressure for Assad to
negotiate a deal with the rebels because
we haven't been willing to put military
pressure on him and I fear that we can
you know ask for a military pressure on
Assad til the cows come home but as long
as Germany isn't willing to lead the way
I don't think America is gonna do that
right now so where is many top elite
nothing you out and you know you've got
a hundred a hundred
um trainers from the bonus fair in the
Kurdish part of the rocky should have a
thousand there it's expensive so if we
want to change the situation on the
ground we're gonna have to invest more I
don't see America interested investing
and to be honest I don't think Germany
is interested in getting in a fight
there it's got Ukraine it's got grease
so here we are four years into this
tragedy and I fear the answers are
easier than the question how did we get
the will to pay the price to fix it let
me now come back a bit later to the
regional power politics surrounding this
but let's take a look first of all at
the situation on the ground in Syria
Mohammed and his brothers are getting a
rare chance to just be kids the boy's
father died a year ago keep it fighting
with rebel forces I'm praying to Allah
that I'll be the best student in second
grade and that my father who's in
paradise is happy
after four years of war massive
destruction and human rights abuses in
Syria continue the Syrian army dropped
barrel bombs filled with explosives and
sharp pieces of metal on a residential
area of Aleppo these are all civilians
and Families I don't know what to say
since the early morning they've been
bombarding us bomb after bomb fighter
jets over a region near Damascus this
recent video shows how people live in
fear and there are still suspected
chemical attacks against civilians on
Monday an alleged chlorine gas attack
killed six people in the province of
inland the Syrian military called the
claim propaganda civilians are being
killed and injured not just by assad
troops but also by rebel groups and
Islamic state militants the fighting and
the suffering are displacing millions
both within Syria and beyond
twenty-four thousand refugees have gone
to Egypt 235,000 fled to Iraq 620,000
went to Jordan Lebanon has taken in 1.1
million refugees Turkey gave refuge to
1.6 million at 21,000 people have sought
asylum in Germany in total over 3.8
million people have fled from Syria and
there are seven point six million
displaced persons inside the country pub
Estella let's come back to what we saw
in that first report regarding the use
of chlorine gas the opposition and
international NGOs say that the Assad
regime is continuing to use poison gas
does that disqualify it to be a partner
at negotiations in your view I think
this disqualify the the humor right
value in the in the world where when the
fifty percent of the Syrian people
displaces or Olaf ug when fifty percent
of the infrastructure have been
destroyed by Assad regime everybody
talking about the crimes of Isis in the
in the in the West let me this is very
important point 12 reporter we are sorry
that had been killed by terrorists in in
Paris other would have been moved and
touched with this paper we have we have
a hundred of the Syrian people has been
has been killed under torture 500
reporters local reporters was covering
the revolution peaceful reporter have
been killed by the regime and there is
thousand of them now in the end the gel
and under torture nobody take care about
them this is not this double standard is
destroying destroying the region what's
happening now Isis I said that the big
Isis as a result of political fail of
the international political fail of the
Obama administration who was want please
persist to have a agreement not
agreement as a lion meat mullah of Iran
and while he is neglecting all his
traditional alliance in the area for
example Saudi Arabia burst people all
the regional is boiling or even this
regime was historically or the Friends
of knighted state they are boiling they
are changing their attitude and
Christine have point for Iran beside not
controlling Syria now and the aloe is
not controlling Syria now whose
contracts here now is Iran every
everybody knows happy in the ground and
I think all the security people know
that I want to come back to the regional
power situation but let's briefly stay
focused on that you don't yeah for one
point they mentioned about the the power
and public Bashar Assad is strong etc
with the Iranian without that the
Iranian I want to mention for a daraya
this is small town only one kilometer
distance away of Damascus those people
under the siege since two years and
Martha me and and a part of Damascus and
asset cannot enter that that area what
kind of power did this regime with all
this death while in the same time in the
same time our problem with the United
with lighted state not to arming us or
to send a jet or accompanying us our
problem with them and I'm protocol
anovas I'm talking about it's very real
they are making a very big pressure over
Saudi Arabia and Turkey and Qatar for
not arming the opposition with our
opposition I will ensure you within one
on two months we can get this regime and
his allies in from Syria ok let's come
back to that point I'd like though to
talk about the use of poison gas the
Turkish Prime Minister said this week
after this latest report about the use
of poison gas negotiating with Assad and
his regime would be like negotiating
with Hitler but the fact is Andrew
Denison negotiating with war criminals
is more or less standard practice in
ending many conflicts slobodan milosevic
charged with war crimes crimes against
humanity still sat down at the table in
Dayton
exactly Melinda that example was also on
the tip of my tongue Europeans reviewers
would recall in the 90s bloody civil war
in Yugoslavia and Milosevic 'as forces
were bombed locals on the ground were
organized the fight against him but we
also talked to him yeah after bumping
him he was ready to talk yeah Assad
regime does not move unless it feels it
yes it has some real fear in front of
military action this was the red line
with the first can elect attacks in the
summer of two thousand thirty in East
luta of Damascus you know they were
really afraid that now Obama would send
some fighting jets he would not in the
end but this was the moment that he
agreed on delivering his chemical
weapons to the international community
was the only point where he agreed on
any compromise let's say the only reach
i agree with you that without military
pressure Assad is not going to move with
our military pressure Isis is not going
to be defeated in Iraq or Syria the
problem is when Assad is gone when Isis
is gone then what yes we don't want to
go in and police that country and
Europeans don't either so we are in a
difficult situation no I mean is asking
the Americans to go I know really
bothers this would make it even worse
because it is so dynamic is if we arm
them then we own it then there will be
political pressure from around the world
when the civil war continues that
America go in with ground soldiers and
help now if the Syrians attack York New
York City the calculation will change
but as long as the Syrians are just
killing each other and Isis I'm afraid a
cynical view will prevail in Washington
that says like Stalingrad let them kill
each other we don't want to mess with
out any more than politically necessary
and I would say more important at this
point then arming the opposition or
putting military pressure on Assad is
saving the refugees no it's protecting
civility let us particular civilians let
us focus now on the opposition far west
ello is there any group within the
opposition that can present a truly
credible and feasible political
alternative to a Bashar Assad
I know that you yourself resigned from
the Syrian National Council because you
said it was far too lacking in unity and
also undemocratic actually been talking
about the opposition we got to
distinguish between the political
opposition which have been talking to
international community which after
three years now is they prove that they
are big fail failure than that this is
this is a truth in Malaya and they have
almost no connection with the people who
is fighting on the ground the real power
is existing that said you are talking
about the substitute that I said this is
the partnership and talking about
there's a reliable powers military on
civil powers on the ground and fighting
or have the effect on the ground those
people with the internationally can go
with a partnership partnership full
partnership with with them for a full
package of the solution in Syria and in
the in this case you can exactly will it
screws which groups who is this and how
much of the situation on the ground do
they actually control look if you the
opposition is controlling now more than
when talking about one of the three or
cities being controlled by Isis you are
talking about desserts this is nothing
you know Isis has problems in Iran not
just in Syria let's not forget that the
reason America is going after Isis is
not because it's a threat in Syria it's
because Isis holds Fallujah and mosel
and the cities and Americans fought for
for the last 10 years and we have a
responsibility to fix Iraq not to fix
Syria however we might not be rapid
without a rock without fixing Syria but
then we have to be honest about what
it's going to cost otherwise I'm afraid
is that we're just gonna kick the can
down the road to the next crisis or the
community are talking about now about 12
million refugee we can and that's
actually we can help at least to protect
this specific and Tory replace them play
inside Syria when it's had a no-fly zone
no-fly zone these days please do answer
my question exactly whom do you wish us
to support who should get more training
who should get more weapons who's in a
position to actually govern the
country look there is a few get rid of
the we are not I'm talking and not
talking about Al Qaeda groups in Syria
I'm talking were very huge groups in
Syria which controlling actually more
than forty percent of the of the Syrian
territory those people we communication
company can work with them to build this
administration insights here they are
exist on the intelligent security forces
on people always exist now in Syria and
Turkey on Turkey on everywhere who is
having the full studies which may be
issue I am an Android don't know about
they know who they can talk to it not
matter of training it's it's a [ __ ]
it's a joke training or man killing arms
watching gangland killing this is this
is a real joke yeah I mean it spirits
sorry you in the past have cast doubt on
exactly this point you have said the
opposition does not have much control
over the fighting on the ground that
they in fact do not control the factions
that are currently fighting so how do
you want to put this pressure on Assad
via military support for the opposition
of this time does not get it let's clear
this out there's a political opposition
there's National Coalition outside the
country there are two opposition groups
inside the country still operating
inside the country there's an important
point here because they have agreed on a
road map two months ago in 10 points how
to negotiate in which way to negotiate
with this regime and what should this
lead to this is one this is the
political opposition then you have the
military fight inside where you have
hundreds of rebel groups some of them
moderate they were aligned with this
national coalition they kind of
distanced themselves you have every
other week we have new alliances the
major point is there are still inside
Syria a lot of moderate forces being
armed being not on being civilian
resistance activists on the ground local
committees local colour councils and
these are the ones who stand up for the
values that the series in the first
place in 2011 took to the streets for so
there are moderate forces inside Syria
that we just ignore in the West the
problem is the problem in the West is
not just just to finish this because
there's a very we can look to the south
of Syria to the province of data in the
south the situation is different the FSA
the Free Syrian Army or what is left of
it moderate rebel groups work together
in a better way because we have a
military council inside Jordan a us-led
military operation center that is
channeling all the four and eight
foreign military and financial support
to the Syrian groups so there we have a
strong moderate groups whereas in the
north rebel groups go to Turkey they
meet the people from Doha from Riyadh
from Washington everybody has to look
for his own financial financial support
and they compete in this so how do we
want them to go back and cooperate
against jihadists in against the Assad
regime if everybody is just trying to
find his own supports so we have to have
an a strong unified military command and
we will only get this if the u.s. comes
to this conclusion that we have to build
an international support channeling this
to one unified military command that all
the moderate rebels have to listen to
enter dances in the past the conclusion
that many people in the US have arrived
at is that if we send weapons into this
extremely messy disparate situation they
will wind up in the hands of people
fighting us the term known as blowback
is there any reason to believe that we
could actually control this situation
you know Melinda America is conflicted
on this too in the summer of two
thousand twelve as Obama was running for
reelection all of his advisers Clinton
dem z Petraeus Panetta gates they all
said armed the opposition and he said no
now that took backbone and maybe it was
wrong but today as well there are people
including mr. Obama in the White House
who don't want to be involved with it so
the question is why do they do anything
at all and I think that there is an
argument for keeping options open you
want to know who's on the ground and
who's fighting against whom but very
reluctant to give the kind of web
that are necessary so I feared that it's
either going to be a qualitative change
in the nature of the warlike with it
with the chemical weapons attacks that
changes the political mood in Washington
or it's going to have to wait until
another president and we're just going
to keep watching now what could change
the chemical weapons you know we didn't
go to work here sir but we did have
enough pressure to pull the chemical
weapons out and I think that was
actually a success in the future there
may be a situation also where Assad is
all of a sudden very vulnerable and as
an opportunity to take advantage of but
in the current situation I fear the
first target is Isis in Iraq and if we
can fix Iraq then we look at Syria and
maybe a question for both of you is also
whether the Syria of today with its
borders is the Syria we should negotiate
for are we going to see a breakup of
Syria like we saw breakup of yugoslavia
i may add something to this question to
the radical groups where the weapons are
ending up this is actually the major
concerns I feel in Washington because
what happened is that some of these
moderate forces that have been aren't by
the US have been just eaten by the
nusrah front the nusrah front is the
affiliate of al-qaida inside Syria so if
you in Washington want to make sure that
moderate rebels do not work with nostra
form because they need their military
equipment and they need the military
strength then just make sure that they
don't need nostra front the fact is
though Isis is fighting now with many US
weapons which it has captured as it one
territory let's say Isis actually is
pushed back to some degree out of Iraq
the logical place where it to go will be
Syria you actually questioned the
statistic I had said earlier if I was
tell that Isis now controls about half
of Syrian territory you say it's more
like a third couldn't it well wind up
controlling more and what will that mean
for the conflict in your country if in
fact Isis begins to retreat into Syria
look I says did I see it not people who
came from meth as the people who came
from the local community and Isis a
result of this
bad on this failure of Obama
administration before two years there
was no no Isis in Syria and and for two
years before that all the world was
watching yes if you want to to fight
Isis it's the Sunni or in the area the
only people who cover any Iraq now and
like Iraq now is there is a big problem
the sectarian militias who is called
alhaji sharpie now they are fighting
with the Iraqi sectarian Shia government
which will totally controlled by the
Iranian with the full agreement with
with with the American American and now
and now there is about to three thousand
fighters from Iran's community fighting
directly with with them in this area
where the isis is became bigger and
bigger look what's happening now that
Isis is being extended I don't care
about this political statement that we
are making a judgment know that there is
a big fail fail for Obama strategy in
Iraq and Obama non strategy none
announced strategy in in Syria when you
want to get rid of Isis get about ash
have a partnership with the people who
can get rid of Isis first of all the
Sunni or in the region by the way a
Muslim they are not that yes maybe
there's 1,000 or 2,000 persons came from
outside but the most of them they had
real fighter who changed their loyalty
like Christine said to have support to
have a stressor because they have main
priority to get rid of this regime these
are purity this is not i know that i'll
waste have another priority but you have
as in the west to accept our priorities
we want to fight regime as Assad regime
and a neutral in the same time al Qaeda
in the same time but we are not going to
fight al-qaeda with the Assad without I
said we will wait what is happening and
we can fight after all what will
you can in a follow that by the way all
the Europeans they should know the
refugee problem just in the beginning
after one or two years you have to
accept 1 million refugee is it because
because you are doing nothing if you go
I know this is the main problem for the
repeal the refugee and not a state they
think that they are far away they will
not be affected look let me ask Cristen
helper because you have told us several
times we need more military pressure we
need for the u.s. to really to really
make that happen you've heard very
clearly from Andrew Denison about the
ambivalence it's not going to happen in
that way what about the role of the UN
the UN Security Council just a month ago
passed a resolution finally saying that
the use of chemical weapons would be
prohibited and that they would take
military action against the parties if
they were to use them could that be
pressure on Assad could that make a
difference well it only makes it
different if there's anybody ready to go
for it and to really implement these
very few resolutions the Security
Council is paralyzed about Syria so the
very few resolutions that we have seen
last year there were two of them banning
barrel bombs and asking for humanitarian
access to the population inside Syria
both of them are not being implemented
the reports of the international NGO
says this very clearly the situation has
just grown even worse than before the
bearer bonds are used every day they are
raining down you can watch them live
falling into Syria Bashar al-assad
sitting there saying that you know we
are not using barrels we're just using
bombs you know it's it's ridiculous you
know so now again they add we have a
real resolution which is very difficult
because of the power powers inside the
Security Council Russia and China
obviously trying to hold they're
protecting hands of the Assad regime so
we have the resolution if nothing
happens now we have seen chlorine gas
it's a it's clear that it has been used
in it lip again six people one family
wiped out if you watch the videos it's
just terrific Amnesty International
having passed a report it's everything
it's documented everything is clear
everything is well known the you
and institutions themselves are saying
chlorine gas is continuously being used
because it's not forbidden as the
chemical weapon because it can be used
for other purposes so it's all happening
and nobody is ready to take up in the
end this responsibility Andrew Dennison
that blockade in the Security Council of
course very much about the tensions
between the u.s. and russia russia as
the protector of the Assad regime Russia
now says it's going to sponsor a new
round of talks its not afraid to talk to
the Assad regime it does so frequently
it's going to bring together the the
Assad regime and members of the
opposition would you expect anything to
come out of that initiative well Russia
plays a very troublesome role in the
Middle East from my perspective I think
also from Berlin's perspective year the
the government doesn't think it's good
that Russia vetoes or refuses to support
UN Security Council resolutions that
have come over the last four years to
economically isolate the Assad regime to
put more military pressure on it though
with a live with the seal of approval of
the United Nations the same with Iran
and a friend of Assad's regime protected
in the United Nations by the Russians
the old problem you know of the nyet and
so you work around the United Nations
and at the end of the day as tragic as
it is and it is the worst humanitarian
catastrophe of the 21st century as bad
as it is it could be a lot worse it
could be a lot worse if the Assad
government disappeared and no American
soldiers or German soldiers went in it
might really be a war of against all of
against all and those chemical weapons
will come to play and in Iraq to rock
could fall apart um what if Iran doesn't
agree next week on nuclear weapons then
we got a whole nother fight so I fear
our first priority has to be keep things
from getting worse and they could get a
lot worse just a very greatest behind on
who will represent us have this is the
important point what will come after but
situational points we have to focus on
this yes we have a very brief moment
left until the end of the program and I
would like to ask you for was Telo
about a regional solution you've
mentioned a lot of different regional
actors US officials have said look we
need a political solution to this we
need a solution where Iran Saudi Arabia
Turkey all the actors involved in this
region are at the table could it happen
or is it purely utopian at last this is
what's going to happen because now I
think it will it happen and what could
we have the desire from the net united
state and I think that we have to wait
after teledrama finishes his dispute his
period novel I think the Republican and
I hope they will win by the way I'm like
they will can make a big difference in
the in this matter look for the Iranian
all the Syrian people in the revolution
supporting the revolution looking for
them as in Amy's enemies we are not
talking to the people there you'll find
our country just like they are find our
places our our our cities will not talk
to them we are looking for the Russian
as not mediators they are somehow is
partnered with the shell I said all
supporting him politically and and and
then now the Syrian people looking for
the American administration as working
for undercover they are putting the
Russian in the front and the but
actually they are working together I
want to mention something since three
years with every diplomats or politician
from the West I have met they were
saying go and talk to the Russian they
are in the same boat Kristen helberg
very briefly regional solution possible
and who could make it happen well
everybody's meddling inside Syria
whoever meddles inside has to be part of
the solution has to sit at the table but
still the situation is not the Russians
are not trying to get a real solution
they are trying to keep Bashar al-assad
to make it look like some opposition
figures sitting here and then talking to
them nobody will agree to this some real
opposition figures they will not go
there and talk about the future of us a
table talk about power transition and in
the end a future without bjarnason so
the Russians have to accept if they want
to keep say inside Syria they should
accept
the figure potala said in the silk
security apparatus has to be resolved
and let's look for other partners thank
you thank you very much to all of you
for being with us today thanks to you
out there for tuning in
you